[Aplausos]
[Música]
a finales del mes de marzo de 2023
hiroshiyama un ejecutivo de 50 años que
trabajaba para estelas Pharma una de las
farmacéuticas más grandes de Japón
desapareció se esfumó lo hizo en su
último día en China justo antes de
regresar a tierras niponas tras 20 años
trabajando en el gigante asiático Claro
que poco después se supo porque había
desaparecido el señor ni si llama había
sido detenido por la policía china que
le acusaba Ni más ni menos que de ser un
espía o al menos de participar en
actividades de espionaje El problema
queridos amigos de visualpolitik no es
ya que podamos dudar o no de su
fundamento El problema es que es el
décimo octavo japonés detenido y acusado
de lo mismo desde el año 2015 de hecho
la sospechas y las acusaciones de
espionaje se han convertido en todo una
moda en este país 15 de mayo de 2023
China condena a un ciudadano
estadounidense a cadena perpetua por
espionaje y ojo porque la moda del
espionaje no solo afecta a casos
aislados
los medios de comunicación estatales han
puesto en la Diana a las empresas de
consultoría y auditoría muchas de las
cuales estarían Aparentemente siendo
investigadas por las agencias de
seguridad nacional esto ha hecho que por
ejemplo en la encuesta de riesgo
político que elabora Oxford analítica
entre varias multinacionales chinas se
haya convertido ya en el segundo país
con mayor riesgo político de todo el
mundo tan solo por detrás de Rusia y
esto también ayuda a explicar lo que ya
os hemos dicho un montón de veces que
aunque china sigue siendo un destino
importantísimo cada vez más empresas
están estudiando como diversificar su
actividad productiva fuera de este país
y es que puede que no esté teniendo un
gran impacto mediático pero lo cierto Es
que las últimas decisiones del gobierno
chino están haciendo saltar las alarmas
en muchas multinacionales hablamos
incluso de un cambio en la ley de
contraespionaje que puede poner en el
ojo del huracán a un montón de empresas
y profesionales La pregunta es qué
demonios está pasando en China Por qué
están saltando muchas alertas rojas está
acá solo el gobierno de shipping
utilizando la legislación sobre
espionaje para presionar castigar o
cortar lazos con algunas empresas
extranjeras que puede suponer todo esto
para el futuro económico de la República
popular china pues presta mucha pero que
mucha atención porque en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas y lo Primero lo primero saber
es dónde empezó todo atentos
el cerrojazo
todo empezó en el año 2014 apenas un año
después de Queen se convirtiera en el
presidente todopoderoso de china con
titulares como este el parlamento chino
aprueba una ley de contraespionaje la
nueva ley Define el espionaje y otorga
las agencias de seguridad nacional
autoridad para confiscar bienes esta
nueva ley sustituía a la ley de
seguridad Nacional de 1993 y le concedió
a las agencias de seguridad nacional la
capacidad de tener y perseguir las
actividades que a su juicio se
considerarán perjudiciales para la
seguridad nacional también permitía la
incautación de bienes y propiedades y el
derecho a confiscar cualquier
dispositivo dinero o bien Cualquier tipo
de cosa que estuviera relacionada con el
espionaje así imping le gusta tenerlo
todo atado y bien atado así que por
supuesto tras aprobarse esta ley
comenzaron las detenciones
por ejemplo el 15 de julio de 2016
cuando estaba a punto de tomar un avión
de regreso a Japón el investigador
hidelli Suzuki fue detenido él no sabía
el motivo de acusaron de ser un espía en
el juicio se enteró de que una de las
razones era haberle preguntado a un
colega que era funcionario chino si
sabía algo de la supuesta ejecución por
parte de Kim jong-un de su tío al final
no hubo mucha historia pero fue
condenado a seis años de cárcel las
condiciones él mismo lo cuenta la parte
mástil fue Durante los primeros siete
meses de mi detención las cortinas
estaban cerradas en esa habitación solo
pude ver el sol durante 15 minutos con
un permiso especial lloré cuando lo vi
hidelli Suzuki en 2017 cuatro empleados
de la NC geofísical y dos empleados de
otra empresa local también fueron
detenidos en 2018 las autoridades chinas
reaccionaron al arresto por parte de
Canadá de la directora financiera de
Huawei men One show deteniendo a dos
canadienses por cargos de espionaje
aunque no se presentaron evidencias son
sólo tres ejemplos de muchos más casos
claro y eso tan solo fue el comienzo
[Música]
sobre todo en los últimos años el
gobierno chino se ha puesto las pilas
para incrementar su control sobre casi
todo en 2021 la administración del
ciberespacio de China presentó muchas
nuevas restricciones a la exportación de
datos restricciones que pasaron a estar
en vigor a partir del día 1 de
septiembre de 2022 y que ya le están
complicando mucho la vida a un montón de
empresas y profesionales de todo tipo
por ejemplo estas normas están
restringiendo el acceso de empresas
inversores y profesionales a información
contable de empresas chinas a
información sobre patentes revistas
académicas o series estadísticas de todo
tipo Este es por ejemplo el caso de la
base de datos más importante de todo el
país la que maneja la Wind information
con sede en shanghái una enorme fuente
de datos económicos y financieros que
hasta ahora era ampliamente utilizada
por analistas e inversores extranjeros
sin embargo eso se está volviendo cada
vez más complicado
en la misma línea en 2019 otro
investigador de la Universidad de
hokkaido también fue detenido hoy 5
japoneses están detenidos en China por
acusaciones muy similares de espionaje
hace No mucho tiempo los empleados de la
oficina de Shanghai de la consultora
norteamericana Company fueron
interrogados en otra consultora
estadounidense la mins Group detuvieron
a cinco trabajadores en marzo de 2023
Pekín anunció una revisión de
ciberseguridad contra la empresa de
semiconductores estadounidenses micron
Technology una revisión que ha terminado
prohibiendo la comercialización de
varios de los productos de esta empresa
en el país de la misma forma la policía
también visitó por sorpresa la oficina
de la empresa norteamericana de
networking y consultoría Kat Vision
queridos amigos el gobierno chino se ha
obsesionado con los datos Y eso es
exactamente lo que explica noticias como
estos china encierra la información
sobre el país una caja negra con todo la
medida potencialmente más importante y
cuyas repercusiones pueden llegar a ser
mucho más graves llegó con el comienzo
del segundo trimestre del 2023 fijaos
china aprueba una amplia expansión de la
ley de lucha contra el espionaje
queridos amigos el 26 de abril el
principal órgano legislativo la asamblea
popular nacional aprobó una
importantísima reforma de la ley de
contrasteonaje del 2014 una reforma que
ha hecho saltar las alarmas de empresas
inversores y gobiernos de todo el mundo
la pregunta es por qué pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver presta mucha atención
porque las repercusiones de este cambio
pueden llegar a ser mucho más
importantes de lo que imaginas
Por cierto un apunte echando un vistazo
a las estadísticas hemos visto que
todavía más del 40% de las personas que
veis visualpolitik no estáis suscritas
al Canal La pregunta es a qué estáis
esperando si os gusta la política la
economía los asuntos internacionales ir
directamente a las claves que nos
permiten entender lo que ocurre en el
mundo y además pasar un buen rato no
dejéis de suscribiros y activar la
campanita es 100% gratuito
[Música]
El golpe definitivo
queridos amigos amigas la última reforma
de la ley de contraespionaje de China ha
hecho saltar todas las alarmas La
pregunta es por qué Pues básicamente
porque esta reforma incorpora 5 grandes
cambios primero se amplía el alcance de
la leía todos los documentos datos
materiales o artículos que a juicio del
gobierno puedan estar relacionados con
la seguridad y los intereses nacionales
sin importar ojo que sean públicos o
privados y es que de hecho la ley ni
siquiera Define En qué consiste o Qué
ámbitos que dan bajo el concepto de
seguridad nacional y Qué quiere decir
esto pues lo vamos a ver en un momento
pero básicamente que todo queda al
árbitro de gobierno segundo la reforma
también incrementa el control sobre el
ciberespacio tercero se le concede más
poder a los cuerpos de seguridad para
inspeccionar e incluso incautar el
equipaje y los dispositivos electrónicos
de cualquier persona que pueda ser
sospechosa de tratar con datos delicados
cuarto todos los ciudadanos y
organizaciones chinas tendrán que
denunciar cualquier sospecha de
espionaje a riesgo de ser considerados
ellos mismos Cómplices si no lo hacen y
ya sabéis lo que esto puede suponer
básicamente esto puede hacer que
cualquier conducta pueda llegar a ser
considerada sospechosa luego veremos
algún ejemplo concreto los académicos
extranjeros como yo ahora evitarán ir a
China si podemos Por qué cosas como los
comentarios en las redes sociales
podrían verse como evidencia de haber
cometido espionaje a los ojos del
gobierno chino como coaco académico de
la Universidad de Tokio y quinto se
prohibirá la salida del país a cualquier
persona ojo nacional o incluso llegado
el caso extranjera que esté bajo
investigación no procesada o que se
considere que su salida supone un riesgo
para la seguridad nacional para que os
hagáis una idea según datos de reuters
entre los años 2016 y 2022 se multiplicó
por 8 el número de prohibiciones de
salida Así que imaginaos lo que puede
ocurrir ahora a partir de esta reforma
pero un momento vamos a ver por qué una
ley de espionaje ha desatado tantas
alarmas entre las empresas pues sobre
todo porque se entromete de lleno en el
funcionamiento de las compañías privadas
[Música]
Y es que la ley ya no solo habla de
secretos de estado sino de cualquier
tipo de información o de dato y claro el
problema es que cualquier empresa para
poder funcionar más o menos
correctamente pues necesita que sus
ejecutivos tengan información por
ejemplo necesitan conocer las tendencias
de la industria las preferencias de los
consumidores sus niveles de ahorro las
patentes que se están publicando los
diseños industriales que genera la
propia empresa los datos de sus rivales
etcétera etcétera sin embargo ahora
tener este tipo de información puede
suponer un enorme problema y Exactamente
lo mismo ocurre con las empresas de
servicios profesionales con las que
puedan colaborar auditores consultores o
abogados ahora si son extranjeros tienen
que trabajar con un tipo de información
que podría llegar a meterlos en la
cárcel tras un juicio que además para
colmo en el caso de las acusaciones de
espionajes y realiza en secreto sin
luces ni taquígrafos es decir en otras
palabras y ahora cualquier persona que
haya manejado información delicada de un
proyecto o de una empresa en China
podría llegar a ser acusado Ni más ni
menos que por la ley de contra espionaje
y ojo porque ni siquiera se requiere que
se acredite de su trabajo para una
extranjera y esto Esto es un importante
problema Un problemón porque
prácticamente cualquier persona puede
llegar a ser arrestada y culpada de
cargos de espionaje que lógicamente como
os podéis imaginar Pues es de lo peor
que te puede pasar en la mayor parte de
países del mundo y especialmente Claro
está en autocracias como la china se ha
hecho aún más difícil prever la
situación y las empresas se verán
obligadas a ser más cautelosas en muchos
aspectos director de la asociación
japonesa de ejecutivos de empresa la
actualización de la ley contra el
espionaje del partido comunista chino
Envía una señal alta y clara al mundo en
China no existen las empresas privadas
el estado Se reserva el derecho de
confiscar arbitrariamente y cualquier
propiedad robar cualquier propiedad
intelectual recopilar cualquier dato
congresista republicano Mike Gallagher
presidente del comité selecto sobre el
partido comunista chino y no solo eso la
propia emisora pública hace ctv ha
cargado contra empresas de consultoría
por supuestamente causar daño a la
seguridad nacional
Así que ahora por ejemplo para evitar
ser acusados de espionaje en cualquier
momento las empresas los ejecutivos y
los inversores pues tendrán que trabajar
con los datos oficiales que el gobierno
decida publicar sin poder intentar
obtener y recopilar información por sí
mismos salvo Claro está se quieran
arriesgar a terminar en el tuyo y esto
Esto es solo una de las muchas posibles
consecuencias además ahora cualquier
acusación por el motivo que sea puede
terminar con las agencias de seguridad
Nacional registrando los dispositivos
electrónicos y las oficinas de las
empresas extranjeras lo que claro está
podría exponer secretos comerciales y
propiedad intelectual mucho ojo con esto
porque qué queréis que os diga teniendo
en cuenta el historial de china en esta
materia cuidado y esto es lo que explica
que en Estados Unidos Este es un tema
que genera cada vez más y más inquietud
nuestros dirigentes empresariales tienen
que quitarse la venda dorada de los ojos
y reconocer que la reciente redadas
policiales en las empresas
estadounidenses no son casos aislados
sino que forman parte de una larga y
altiva tradición de explotación
congresista republicano Mike Gallagher
el congreso debería probar una
legislación que faculta la comisión de
valores y bolsa para limitar el flujo de
fondos a China el esfuerzo debe
disfrutar de un apoyo bipartidista
George soros Claro que dicho esto la
pregunta que Seguro seguro muchos os
estáis haciendo es Pero por qué Qué gana
el gobierno chino poniendo en la Diana
la información y los datos privados pues
probablemente nada pero amigos amigas en
Pekín están obsesionados
fundamentalmente con tres cosas
primero tal y como defiende el activista
experto legal y profesor de la
Universidad de ciencias políticas y
derecho de China Pekín con todo este
control el gobierno quiere evitar que
las potencias extranjeras puedan llegar
a instigar una revolución de colores en
China y vale puede que penséis que este
escenario pues no es que parezca el más
probable del mundo pero sea como sea en
Pekín parecen obsesionados Con tener el
control y evitar que nada pueda afectar
al actual régimen si todas las empresas
están atadas en corto mejor que mejor
segundo el gobierno quiere controlar la
narrativa sobre el estado real de la
economía China y es que ella sabéis que
la economía china pues no atraviesa su
mejor momento
juvenil estaba haciendo récords solo
crece la inversión pública y el sector
exterior se está desacelerando quiere
decir esto que el milagro chino está
llegando a su fin pues Por si las moscas
epikin tienen Claro que cuanto menos se
sepa mejor que mejor y tercero el
gobierno también quiere impedir a toda
Costa que los datos de las empresas de
la industria y de las tecnológicas de
China abandonen el país para ser usados
por rivales del resto del mundo ahora
bien dicho esto la pregunta que Seguro
seguro muchos tenéis en la cabeza es y
cómo puede afectar todo esto a la
economía China y si acaso en Pekín
quieren conseguir que las empresas
extranjeras se larguen del país pues
nada más lejos de la realidad atentos
brazos abiertos
[Música]
ya lo veis estamos ante el último gran
quebradero de cabeza que el régimen del
partido comunista chino está provocando
a las empresas extranjeras en el país y
también a las propias empresas locales
Claro que esta no es la primera
zancadilla en los últimos años hemos
visto por ejemplo la guerra que el
gobierno de chimping desató contra las
grandes tecnológicas chinas comenzó a
finales de 2020 cuando Pekín paralizó la
salida a bolsa del brazo financiero de
alibaba tras unas declaraciones críticas
de Jack ma que fueron algo así como la
ota que colmó el vaso para los
gerifaltes de Pekín a partir de ese
momento se lanzó una campaña de nuevas
reglas multas limites bloqueos a
operaciones corporativas y mucho más
control de todas estas empresas por
parte del partido comunista su objetivo
limitar el poder cada vez mayor que
estos grupos estaban acaparando en el
país
atreverse a criticar a silvin donde se
habrá visto
Y no sólo eso Poco después el 17 de
agosto del 2021 se impulsó el conocido
plan para la prosperidad común para
limitar los beneficios excesivos que
según el gobierno muchas empresas
estaban teniendo es decir por primera
vez en muchos años el gobierno chino
volvió a poner en la Diana los
beneficios de las empresas pero seguimos
al mismo tiempo el gobierno chino
también comenzó a reforzar su presencia
en el capital y sobre todo en la
dirección de las grandes compañías para
que os hagáis una idea ahora tanto las
empresas estatales como las privadas
tienen al máximo nivel incluso por
encima del presidente de la propia
empresa aún representante del partido
para fiscalizar y participar en la toma
de decisiones son solo tres ejemplos a
los que se suman toneladas de nuevas
regulaciones y ahora también la reforma
de la ley de contraspionaje que acabamos
de ver y claro con todo esto en mente la
gran pregunta que parece estar sobre la
mesa es es que acaso el gobierno chino
quiere espantar a las empresas privadas
Pues lo más sorprendente de todo es que
Aparentemente no
todos estos planes chocan de frente con
las otras dos grandes prioridades del
gobierno convertir a China en la gran
referencia económica del mundo y sobre
todo en el corto plazo alentar nuevas
inversiones extranjeras para impulsar su
economía y superar todos los baches en
los que están metidos todo el mundo
quiere que invirtamos más parece un poco
como si la mano izquierda no supiera lo
que está haciendo la mano derecha York
budge presidente de la cámara de
comercio de la Unión Europea en China de
hecho el Primer Ministro de China se
encuentra en plena campaña para intentar
mejorar la imagen del país y no se cansa
de repetir una y otra y otra vez que
china está abierta los negocios el
gobierno chino ha dicho continuamente
que da la bienvenida a la inversión
extranjera sin embargo una oleada de
acciones recientes tomadas de nuevo por
las empresas estadounidenses en China ha
enviado el mensaje opuesto Michael hard
presidente de la cámara de comercio
americana en China es la gran
contradicción del gobierno chino una
contradicción que está haciendo que por
ejemplo por primera vez en los últimos
25 años en la encuesta de sentimiento
empresarial de la cámara de comercio
americana en China la mayoría de las
empresas hayan respondido que ya no ven
a China como uno de los tres destinos
prioritarios de inversión
sí sin duda este país seguirá siendo
clave por su enorme mercado y las
empresas internacionales seguirán
invirtiendo mucho dinero en él pero cada
vez parece más claro que esta apuesta
está perdiendo fuerza Si antes la idea
era invertir en China para atender Desde
allí todo el mercado mundial ahora La
idea es que las inversiones en China
atiendan especialmente al mercado chino
por ahí parece que van los tiros y
sabéis que esto no es nada bueno para
china que es por otra parte lo que
explica la campaña del Primer Ministro
pero si os parece fijémonos en algunos
datos como podéis ver el desempleo
juvenil está batiendo récords entre
ellos hablamos de casi 12 millones de
titulados universitarios y eso a pesar
de que el envejecimiento haya hecho que
la población activa del país haya caído
en los últimos tres años en más de 40
millones de personas la cosa queridos
amigos de visualpolitik se está poniendo
tan fea que las visitas a los templos se
han multiplicado por cuatro la mitad de
Los visitantes son jóvenes nacidos
a partir de 1990 que van allí a rezar a
hacer ofrendas por un trabajo no es
broma
[Música]
por su parte los medios estatales han
puesto en marcha una campaña para
recriminar a los graduados
universitarios que no acepten empleos en
actividades como la construcción el
campo o la hostelería y no es un
problema aislado la segunda economía más
grande del mundo no Se está disparando
en todos los campos el gasto de los
consumidores está recuperando pero la
fabricación está retrocediendo y las
ganancias industriales están cayendo el
crecimiento de los ingresos de los
hogares es débil y el desempleo juvenil
está cerca de un máximo histórico así
que ya lo veis ahora la reforma de la
ley de contraspionaje promete echar más
gasolina al fuego las reformas chinas
están empezando a complicarle y mucho la
vida a las empresas justo en el momento
en el que más necesitan a las empresas y
la inversión de las empresas de locos os
contaremos muchos más detalles sobre el
estado de China tanto en nuestro boletín
para patronos como en not news nuestra
newsletter abierta y gratuita para todo
el mundo como que no la Pues nada te
dejo el enlace abajo en la descripción
para que te apuntes ya la pregunta es
merece la pena que las empresas
occidentales sigan invirtiendo en China
mantendrán sus inversiones o reducirán
su Apuesta por el gigante asiático Cómo
puede afectar esto a China vosotros qué
haríais déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]